hi everybody good afternoon I hope
everyone has been enjoying the
conference so far the organizers have
done such a fantastic job putting this
together for us and I'm so thankful for
the opportunity to be here today and be
able to get on stage and complain to all
of you for the next half hour
so I'm Brittany I'm an instructor at
Turing School of software and design in
Denver Colorado we teach a pretty
comprehensive curriculum for web
application development and in my
current role I'm focused mostly on
teaching vanilla JavaScript syntax and
the fundamental patterns and concepts
that you need in order to work with the
language so I'm working with people that
are very new to programming I've been in
this role for about a year now and this
has been the most eye-opening experience
of my career so far historically I was
working in strictly engineering roles
and during that time over the past 10
years or so I really lost that beginner
perspective that I had when I first
started out I'm sure a lot of you have
lost that as well
but working with students has brought
that back really fast it's kind of
shoved in my face every single day which
has been really amazing to see so I'll
give you a couple of examples of what I
mean by that but I've started to get
that beginner perspective back because
my students are really struggling with
things and I've started to realize just
how difficult we have made it for new
developers to join us the things that
they struggle with are so fixable and
the one that stands out to me the most
is our error handling and the way that
we have set up this debugging process
for ourselves we've become so complacent
with the way that it currently is and
maybe we don't recognize that it's in a
bad state but brand-new developers
recognize it every single day so I'll
start with with an example a couple
weeks ago I was teaching my
how to deploy their applications to
Heroku and one of my students ran into
this super helpful application error
page and he threw his hands in the air
and he said well that doesn't work and
just moments before that I had taught
them how to look at the air logs in
their terminal so I was being kind of
sassy and I was like well did you read
the error logs and of course he hadn't
so he went back and he read the error
logs and when I came back around a
couple minutes later I was like well so
what did they say and he replied to me
and he said it literally said we need a
better error message here this is a true
story
so getting owned like this is part of my
job now on a daily basis and I'll be
honest I really don't like it it's not
my favorite part of the job so the rest
of this talk is gonna be kind of a plea
to all of you to help me fix these types
of things okay so we're gonna talk about
a couple of ideas on how to fix these
things and how we can make our error
handling ecosystem better and friendlier
for new developers but first I want to
go over how we're encountering these
errors in the first place what are we
doing what kind of mistakes are we
making that's causing us to run into
errors and for the most part we are
making very tiny mistakes I don't care
if you have been programming for ten
years or five months most of our errors
that we encounter are caused by little
typos case sensitivity errors in setup
and configuration no matter what skill
level you're at we are all making these
same very subtle very innocent mistakes
where the divide occurs is that the more
experience you have the easier it is for
you to identify that you just made a
tiny little typo and the faster it is
for you to fix that it almost becomes
intuitive and becomes second nature we
don't even really need to read the error
messages that thoroughly because we're
like Oh
I must have a typo somewhere and we can
find it really quickly for new
developers this is not the case at all
okay I've had so many students be so
close to coming up with a solution for a
particular problem and their code is 99%
accurate but in the face of a really
complex error message they think that
they've done something horribly wrong
and the error messages that we're giving
these developers is leading them astray
it's leading them down the wrong path
so I'll give you a couple of examples of
what I mean by that and how that's
happening to our new developers one
common mistake my students make is
mixing up array and object prototype
methods so in this example we have a PI
object and our developer wanted to add a
new key value pair to this they wanted
to add a new property to this object and
the way that they tried to do it was by
saying PI dot push and pushing in this
key value pair here this is not accurate
it's not going to work but the logic
here is pretty sound so the developer
new pushes a method that I know I have
access to and it is used for adding a
new value to a data structure okay they
happen to be wrong with the data
structure that they're currently working
with but it's not that far off so when
they run this code they got this error
uncaught type error PI dot push is not a
function and as a new developer when I
read this error message my focus is on
this push is not a function part okay
because someone told me that push is
built into JavaScript by default I
shouldn't have to write it I shouldn't
have to define it how could it possibly
not be there right so when I go back to
look at my code I'm now so laser focused
on this push method rather than on what
kind of data type my PI is okay so now I
can't really focus on the area of the
code that I need to in order to debug
this another example is
getting return statements so in this
example we have a calculator class with
a couple of methods and we're creating a
new instance of this calculator and then
we're chaining these methods together so
we're gonna say subtract 3 add 5 add two
add six ok but we have a bug in this
code right now we're forgetting to
return the instance of our calculator in
our add method ok so when we run this
code we get an error message that says
uncaught type error cannot read property
add of undefined as a new developer when
I read this error message all that I can
really glean from this is that for some
reason my calculator is undefined so
when I go back to my code I'm gonna
check did I spell calculator right up
here
am i instantiating it correctly and I'm
a new developer so I'm really not super
confident in the syntax that I'm using
here maybe I'm going to play around with
adding and removing this new keyword
maybe I don't need that maybe I'm gonna
remove these parens at the end of my
instantiation I'm doubting myself and
this error message is making me doubt
areas of my code that were perfectly
fine but now I'm gonna mess them up and
I'm gonna put myself even further from a
solution than I was the first time
around okay I'm gonna check that these
Cal variables are spelled correctly and
I'm not typoing anything there but
that's pretty much the exhaustive list
of what I can think of to debug when I
get an error message that looks like
that okay final example here a lot of
students will mess up on checking
truthiness versus assigning values so in
this scenario we have a PI variable set
equal to rhubarb and what the intent of
this code is is to run a conditional
that says if the pious strawberry we're
gonna console.log boo and otherwise
we're gonna say yay okay
so I'm expecting this to console.log yay
right now but it's not going to because
I'm accidentally assigning pie to
strawberry directly in my if condition
okay
this is not a fundamental
misunderstanding of how the language
works this could be as simple as a typo
and look at how hard it is to recognize
that if you're a new developer this is
the difference of one or two equal signs
that you're missing here and what's
nastier about a problem like this is
that you're not going to get an error
message in the console to lead you in
any direction you're just gonna see that
your code is broken and you don't know
why it's not doing what you expected it
to as far as I know there's also not
even an es lint rule that will warn you
about this correct me if I'm wrong but I
checked on it last night and I did not
find one is there what's it called look
it up let me know thank you okay but
it's really hard for them to decipher
where these little typos are okay so the
unfortunate truth right now is that the
consequences of making a very tiny
innocent mistake are so much greater for
new developers than it is for senior
engineers they're spending five hours to
debug the same thing that it would take
a senior engineer to debug in one minute
okay they're spinning their wheels a lot
our error handling ecosystem right now
is the biggest technical barrier to
entry for new developers this this is
the thing that's holding them back the
most from being successful in tech right
at the start okay so this is one of
those things that we really need to
focus on and we really need to fix I
want to talk about this barrier a little
bit why it exists how it came to be in
the state that it's currently in and I'm
gonna start by making some excuses for
ourselves because that feels really good
so why is error handling so bad as
JavaScript developers we have some
unique challenges that other ecosystems
don't necessarily have to deal with for
one we are working in a dynamically
typed language which adds a set of
intricacies that we don't necessarily
see elsewhere on the client-side we
cross-browser and cross for mist in seas
that we have to work with and our
testing infrastructure is still very new
it's still very fragile and difficult to
navigate and if you don't agree with
that statement please take that as a
sign that you have lost some of your
beginner perspective as well because it
is ok it's harder for us to rely on
automated testing than it is for some
other languages and some other coding
environments ok so these factors are all
the more reason for us to be focusing
and working even harder on our error
handling and we can't simply excuse
ourselves from this type of work because
in a lot of ways error handling is
predictably bad there are a lot of
things that we're doing that we can
prevent in order to increase the the
empathy and friendliness of diba the
debugging process for new developers ok
so one of the first things that we're
doing wrong is we're writing error
messages for ourselves rather than our
users we pride ourselves on being a very
user focused user centric community and
Industry and I do believe that we put
our best effort into making really good
user experiences in some contexts but I
do also think that we have some blind
spots here so when our users are
developers we kind of latch on to that
similarity we say oh they're a developer
just like me they're gonna understand
things the same way that I do okay and
that's not the case we're starting to
neglect the differences in skill level
and backgrounds and experience and those
things have a huge impact on the way
that people work with your technology
and the things that they're gonna try to
do with it in the ways that they're
gonna try to break it okay bigger
problem is that we're working with
computers and computers are kind of dumb
the programs that we write can only
understand so much about intent the
software that we write can only figure
out what you take guesses at what a user
is actually trying to do here so this
leads to error messages that look like
this this is a really popular one that
my students
run into has anyone ever seen this one
yeah lots of hand see how obnoxious is
that one so unexpected token in JSON at
position zero a lot of my students will
run into this when they are expecting a
network response to be of a certain
content type and they get something
completely different so this error
message does tell me that there's some
kind of problem trying to parse this
JSON it did tell me what was going wrong
but it didn't really hint at the fact
that I might be working with a different
content type right so programs are
really good at telling us what went
wrong but not very good about telling us
why something went wrong so this error
message would need a little bit of
additional code a little bit more manual
effort in order to humanize it a little
bit and I don't think we're always
putting in that effort and I think it's
obvious we have historically treated
error handling as a secondary priority
and it shows I did a very quick github
search for better errors and resulted in
about a million issues about a hundred
fifty thousand of them were related to
JavaScript repos and I know this is not
a perfect data point by any means but I
still think it's kind of telling and I
think one of the causes for this is
somewhat related to that theory of
broken windows where if something's a
little bit broken in one place it's much
more acceptable for it to be broken
everywhere else and be broken worse so a
JavaScript developer can get away with
having poor error handling in their
tools because we're used to it by now
and we're complacent with that now
you'll hardly be recognized for
neglecting such a thing okay I think a
bigger cause of this goes back to that
idea of intent so in order to write good
error messages we need to have some data
on what people are trying to do with our
tools how they're working with them how
they're breaking them and in order to
get that data we need users so this
forces us into this waiting period where
we have to let users struggle with our
technology for a little while so that we
can better figure out how to help them
with those problems so this forces us to
put error-handling on the back burner
for a while while we kind of wait for
that feedback to come in and then we
have a really hard time bringing it back
to the front and reprioritizing that
okay so this might all seem like quite a
bit for us to overcome but when things
are predictably terrible and failing in
predictable ways it also means it is
easy to fix so we have a lot of
solutions here and this responsibility
belongs on all of us but I do want to
point out a couple of key players not by
any means to cast any blame but to
rather make it easier for us to identify
where we should be helping out and where
we can be helping out okay where these
problem is actually alive so the first
player we have is the Ekman script stick
spec itself the language and the
language defines a couple of different
error objects different types of error
objects for us and for the most part I
think that the errors that we run into
when we're working with JavaScript do
fall pretty nicely into these buckets
these categories that have been defined
for us but the problem with these is
that it doesn't provide us with that
much much context you really have to do
your research on what these error types
represent in order to glean any
information out of it and I've often
noticed that my students will completely
ignore the part of an error in their
console that says type error : set a
syntax error : and they will skip
directly to the error message to figure
out what went wrong so they're not even
really looking at this okay and those
error messages are often written by
platform engineers platform engineers
are going to determine what kind of
information users need application
developers need when they run into a
particular error and sometimes those
messages are really helpful and then
sometimes they're more like this and
it's not quite as useful
okay so those are two two points of
contact that we have already where
people are shaping the way that we're
getting these error messages back the
third one I want to identify as the
maintainer Xand contributors to
frameworks and libraries so you might be
working with react or ember and they
have implemented their own error
handling for when you do things wrong
this is a tweet from one of my former
students who ran into this uncaught
error cannot find module she was
building a react application at the time
and one thing that I really like about
this tweet is that she kind of makes an
assumption that because she's working
with react the problem must lie within
react but in reality this could have
been a typo in a file name a miss
configuration of webpack a bad
import/export statement this error could
have come from anywhere but it's really
hard for new developers to identify
where this is coming from when this is
the only information that we're giving
them okay so if this student had
happened to be brave enough to file an
issue on the react repo and say hey I'm
running into this problem likely what
would have happened would be that she
would be politely directed to other
resources support resources a react
channel for getting additional help and
then her issue would be closed and maybe
she would join in a slack channel for
people that are helping out with with
react problems and somebody there would
say oh it's actually your your webpack
configuration is a little bit messed up
and it's missing that file so it's not
getting into your bundle that's why
you're getting that error and that's
great now her problem is solved and her
application is working just fine but the
problem of this vague error message is
still not solved okay react could say
well it wasn't our problem it turned out
to be a webpack issue right and then
webpack could say well technically
everything is working fine on our end
there's
failure here it was a user error our
tech stocks are so deep now that it's
very easy for everyone to skirt this
responsibility of fixing our error
handling because everyone just says oh
well it's not my problem
ok and that's one of the first things
that we need to address if we're going
to fix this error handling issue that we
have ok
so not only do we need to be filing
issues about our bugs we need to be
filing issues about the problems that
we're having with our problems ok so
it's a little bit meta but we need to
tell maintainer Xand and relevant
engineers that it's not ok to have this
poor error handling and if you are a
library maintainer or a framework
maintainer don't just close those issues
find a way to either make it your
problem or find out whose problem it
should be and make it theirs don't just
ignore those problems next time you are
working through a bug and you're running
into a difficult time solving it
don't just solve the problem for
yourself and say great my application
works and wipe your hands and move on
think about what made it possible for
you to make that mistake in the first
place what made it harder for you to
solve what information might have made
that debugging process easier and who
might be able to fix this this is the
kind of information that people need
these are the kind of issues that we
need to be filing I think we pride
ourselves on being kind of a selfless
community where we are so open and
willing and ready to share our knowledge
and our work for free which is great of
us I love that about our community but
when it comes to filing an issue that
might help some unknown developer two or
three years down the road who you will
never speak to and you will never know
that you helped them I think we're very
selfish we don't do that nearly often
enough and we need to start ok take the
time make it impossible for some other
developer to make the same mistake that
you made ok next thing we need to do is
start working more with junior
developers and depending on what kind of
technology you're working with or what
kind of error handling you're trying to
improve a junior might mean someone that
is brand new to programming or someone
that maybe has some experience but
they're new to your language or they're
new to your particular technology so I
use that term junior with a lot of
flexibility here but this is going to
take care of that blind spot that we
have when we're trying to build for
developers I mentioned we think our
users are developers they understand
everything the same way that I do but
that's not the case they you need to be
building your technology for all skill
levels you want as many people as
possible to be included in the
opportunity to use whatever it is that
you're building
so juniors are gonna ask the best
questions and provide you with the most
insight into what's confusing or what's
broken I can't tell you how much I've
learned from my students over the past
year just because of the very weird
questions that they ask and the even
weirder things that they try to do I'm
shocked every day at what they tried to
do okay so juniors are gonna help you
conduct the most thorough user testing
that you possibly can okay one thing
that juniors are gonna need though I can
give you a hint right now it's gonna be
more context than we've been providing
them with so my favorite example that I
love to hate is this e adder in use
error that gets surfaced it's an error
code from libuv I get surfaced when
you're running an Express server node
server on a port that's already taken do
you know how my students try to tell me
what's wrong when they get this error I
walk around and I asked them what their
problem is and they say I don't know II
during Eid removes seed renew see they
know it's important because it's in all
caps
but they have no idea what that sense or
what that means even if this just said
error address in use that would be more
helpful that would be more readable for
people so I don't know why we do things
like this if anyone knows please
enlighten me later
but they're gonna need more verbosity
than this and I think one community
where people are doing this really well
is in Elm has anyone worked with Elm
people like it yeah what do we think of
the error handling the best right so
good ok so don't worry if you can't read
this I will obviously send out a link to
my slides later but this is an example
of an error in Elm and look at how
beautifully verbose this is this is so
much information not only is this
anticipating what the user was trying to
do but it's also offering potential
solutions and then also offering
additional links to read more about that
concepts that they're trying to work
with this is the kind of context that we
need with our error messages when we're
working in working with new developers
this makes me think back to that initial
example that I brought up where students
are confusing array.prototype methods
with object prototype methods and we got
that error message that said pipe push
is not a function and this wasn't super
helpful for us right so I even look at
the context that we have here I have a I
have a line number of where it occurred
I also have a line number there where it
occurred if I open this to expand it and
get more details with this little
triangle I get another link to the line
number where it occurred but I don't get
anything useful I don't get any extra
information I would love to see the UI
of this change slightly so that when you
expand an error instead of getting a
third link to the same exact place you
get information like pushes an array
prototype method you happen to be
calling it on an object read more about
that here read more about prototype
methods here okay junior developers
don't know how to read call stacks we
really need to rethink call stacks all
together I know the Firefox developers
are doing a good job thinking about that
and prioritizing that but I can also
tell you that these three links in this
small amount of real estate new
developers don't click on those at all
maybe they clicked on them once and then
they saw the sources panel and they got
really freaked out and scared cuz I
didn't know what was going on or they
didn't realize how useful it was and
then they never click on them again ok
so we need to find some way to add some
more friendly context to these error
messages besides just these call stacks
I'm not saying call stacks are not
helpful obviously they're incredibly
helpful but it takes a while to get used
to reading those ok so coming up with
more elegant solutions like that looking
at that Elm solution thinking about that
PI dot push error message coming up with
these solutions takes a little bit of
research we need that intent data right
so we're waiting for our users to
struggle a little bit with our
technology so that we can figure out how
they're using it how they're breaking it
what problems are running into you I can
tell you that we have already struggled
that intent data is already out there
for so many aspects of JavaScript
development all we need to do is gather
it and leverage it so gathering this
comes from reading through issues that
are files and bugs that are reported
look through Stack Overflow and don't
just look at the questions look at the
answers and look at what questions they
had about those answers what kind of
clarification did they need pay
attention to conversations that are
happening in slack channels and support
networks a lot of times these
conversations will help one person it'll
be a little one-off solution for one
person and then that conversation will
disappear forever and it will never help
anyone improve that technology improve
that resource ok so we need to be
documenting those things and then offer
to be a mentor for a technology that
you're looking to improve being a mentor
you will learn so much like I've said
juniors are the most enlightening people
to work with so being a mentor is going
to ramp up your user testing and and
your ability to anticipate what's going
to go wrong tenfold okay once we have
all that data we need to aggregate all
of the resources that are going to help
people with their intent and one example
that I think we're doing this really
well is in the audits panel of Chrome's
dev tools if you're running an audit you
get this really nice list of everything
that you did right and everything that
you did wrong and when you expand on
each of these results you get a link to
learn more and these learn more links
will send you to a blog post or a
tutorial to learn more about exactly
what's failing or exactly what
successful one thing I do is my students
is I have them run an audit on a
particular webpage and I have them just
list out all the vocabulary that they're
unfamiliar with or things that don't
make sense to them right away and then I
have them go through all of these
resources that are listed here for them
and read them and by the time they're
done looking through those resources
they can speak to almost all of that
vocabulary that they didn't understand
at the beginning of the day and this is
a great example and I think it's a
little bit easier in this scenario
because our intent is very easy to
assume here we can say if you're running
a performance audit on your application
very likely you're trying to make your
application more performant intent kind
of varies in other realms a little bit
so it's a little bit trickier to
implement something like this in other
contexts I think but what I want us to
take away from from this UI is
aggregating those resources and putting
them in one place like putting them
right where users are running into their
error so that they don't have to go
searching for them new developers don't
know where to look for these resources
they don't even know how to Google yet
necessarily constructing proper search
terms to learn more about the errors
that they're encountering is very
difficult it may seem very intuitive for
you but believe it or not that is still
a skill that has
to be learned and it takes some time so
if we can aggregate those resources and
put them right at their point of error
we save them that step of trying to
figure out how to search for them okay
another skill that junior developers are
really focused on is knowing when to ask
for help so some of my students will be
working on a problem by themselves for
about five hours and an instructor will
come over and point out a single line of
code and fix it in a minute just like
that and the student will just facepalm
in disbelief that they just spent five
hours trying to debug such a trivial
error and in those scenarios I generally
just tell my students well welcome to
programming and I walk away but I don't
want to say that anywhere I don't want
to have to say that any more code is
broken way more often than it is working
and that goes that's the same for us
that happens to us just as frequently as
it happens to junior developers so we
need to show them that we understand
that and we empathize with that the way
that we're gonna do that is by fixing
our error handling encountering errors
should be an informative learning
experience and not a frustrating
roadblock and that's what it is right
now for new developers it's a
frustrating roadblock it's a barrier for
them new developers are not learning
nearly half as fast as they could be
they're not learning from their mistakes
they're running into the same problems
far more many times than is necessary
because they're spinning their wheels at
the sight of these really obscure error
messages that we're giving them okay
they're not learning from these these
mistakes that they're making companies
are really hesitant to hire junior
developers because they fear that they
can't ramp them up fast enough or they
don't have the resources to do so and as
a community we can alleviate so much of
that issue just by fixing our error
handling we can make it so much easier
for new developers to learn so much
faster than they current
we are if we just stop making it so
difficult for them so I really urge you
the next time you are working on a bug
working through an error truly think
about these things and keep it at the
forefront of your mind if you see an
error message that isn't useful try to
file an issue for it I hope that you are
motivated to start improving this area
of our our community but if you're not
quite there yet if you're not quite
feeling that I'll leave you with this
final error message that I find very
inspirational failure is not an option
okay so print this out leave it on your
desk whatever you need to do to keep
this at the forefront of your mind okay
deal it's cool thank you so much for
your time and attention I will post a
link to my slides on Twitter and I'll be
around to the rest of the evening to
talk more about this thank you so much
[Applause]
you